le meilleur lancement de l'émission de
divertissement depuis 14 ans pour m6
d'accord away avec une moyenne de 3
millions 500 mille téléspectateurs et
surtout une surperformance sur les
jeunes à plus de 51 % de ces lots et 25%
sur les moins de 50 ans donc y aura une
deuxième saison
alors oui bien sûr la ba oui bien sûr
qu'on met alors à kevin on aura toujours
quatre ou pas ce qu avec ce sac là je
crois de lego masters et à doha a
recommandé ce que je pourrais faire
c'est que ce soit un petit peu plus
court parce que je trouve que 4 c'est un
peu le dock 2-2 de manière un peu plus
les quatre en marche et ça vaut le coup
dans le cadre d'un marché 25 mai
nasillarde et l'imagination des
candidats quand on regarde cette
émission se dit tous est ce qu'on y
arriverait nous avec des lego parce
qu'on fait des trucs tout pourri avec
des lego est ce qu'on aurait envie de
faire franchement parce qu'à chaque fois
on fait la même chose c'est une fusée
voilà
après plusieurs semaines de ce premier
concours télévisé de création de
structures en lego m6 diffusait hier
soir la finale de lego masters une
émission qui comme les briquettes en
plastique en a fait voir de toutes les
couleurs aux téléspectateurs il ya eu
des moments plus difficiles que d'autres
car si le concours avait bien démarré
avec une audience de 4 millions de
téléspectateurs
très vite les scores des semaines
suivantes ont été plus compliquées en
restant tout de même très satisfaisant
pour la chaîne
que s'est-il passé hier soir pour la
clôture de ce concours 2,7 millions de
fidèles étaient présents devant la
télévision
mais si les téléspectateurs sont
quelques-uns être revenu il était
beaucoup à être déçus on va essayer de
faire avec sur internet nombreux sont
ceux qui ont fait part de leur désarroi
face aux constructions proposé par le
programme et ce n'est pas la seule chose
qui a été critiquée beaucoup ont
également fustigé le choix de faire
gagner le binôme david et sébastien
plutôt que loïc et guillaume qui avaient
visiblement conquis le coeur du public
aurait pas vraiment prévu ce contretemps
un coup dur pour cette toute jeune
émission qui a tout de même réussi à
tirer en moyenne 3,3 millions de
téléspectateurs alors légaux masters
comprenez vous la colère des
téléspectateurs après la finale d'hier
soir la victoire de david et sébastien
se dit oh bah moi je les ai trouvés très
bons mais c'est vrai que bien
ils ont gagné vingt mille euros plus le
trophée moi aussi la possibilité de voir
leurs oeuvres exposées à l'hôpital pour
enfants de necker ça c'est une très
belle initiative est regardée david et
sébastien leurs oeuvres qui a été
critiquée regarder pour tenter de
remporter la victoire
ils ont réalisé un totem gigantesque
alliant leurs deux passions d'un côté
vous avez
le côté de david le côté très technique
et de l'autre côté vous avez mois un peu
plus classique
et puis pour donner un côté à rien ces
oiseaux en origami à papier ou à l'aps
un peu aussi symbole de liberté
d'expression qui est aussi le maître mot
de l'oeuvre et la joie et l'honneur de
vous annoncer que le binôme vainqueur
est celui
david et sébastien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors êtes vous choqué par la colère des
téléspectateurs qui n'ont pas aimé cette
oeuvre
vous n'êtes pas choqué qu'elle s'allume
mais non j'ai pas aimé et en plus
j'étais une balade est un peu sur les
vidéos des émissions étrangères
franchement il faut vraiment club pour
la prochaine saison on voit des choses
spectaculaires
franchement c'est pas très beau ça sert
à ça moi j'adore écouter les goûts les
couleurs moi je comprends très bien il y
avait des choses plus plus de plus
inventer et plus plus belles franchement
on comprend alors oui moi je comprends
pas cette polémique autant dans les
concours de chant il ya un vrai enjeu
sur le gagnant parce que ça peut influer
sur leur carrière
là c'est un concours bon enfant
franchement son seigneur mylène 20000
euros s'est bien passé ce soit pierre
paul ou jacques qui gagnent on s'en fout
bah non non si c'est pierre paul ou
jacques et bah non en fout pas géré a
dit moi j'ai adoré ce totem j'ai trouvé
pop germé coloré est requise ils ont
mérité la victoire
les deux soirées façon si ça avait été
le duo de geek
on aurait dit mais voyons c'est honteux
on est déçu andré crie au scandale
donc station n'est jamais content et a
chanté on est très très bon gagnant
alors et moi ce que j'aimerais voir
c'est le jury parce que le jury
quand ils sont devant les lego sur la
tête de ma mère on dirait qu'ils sont
contraires aux intérêts qui sont en
train de juger le prochain président
d'art est subi ils sont devant l'oeuvre
frère en guinée va marie c'est vraiment
ça a dépassé les mecs toral ans en
classe e
il te parle que de lego tu peu à côté de
ses gants mais ça a pris une fois des
oeuvres d'art qui méritent leur place
dans une galerie ou dans un musée et
qu'ils soient exposées aux puces
honnêtement de loin c'est juste super
fada on ne discerne pas toujours les
matières on voit trop lavric attention
de pas tomber dans la simplicité
il faut faire très attention avec
l'arbre parce que c'est quelque chose
qui peut être un peu bateau là vous avez
énormément de travail vous auriez pu
être choisir une couleur un peu plus
blanche qui aurait donné une teinte un
peu plus joyeuse que ce belge
[Rires]
les mecs ils sont premiers dogmes et de
pourquoi c'est moche et légaux là
franchement raymond alors nam et son
premier degré c'est bien mais moi j'ai
bien aimé mais je comprends la colère
des gens parce que c'est nous du haut le
duo a gagné c'est parce que les gens
voulaient vous les voulez voir il
voulait il voulait d'autres durée
voulait pas de celui là et ça fait ça me
fait penser qu'ils sont en colère des
téléspectateurs qui est ton frère
mais ces gens ils ont jeté leurs rues du
coup pas la face il y avait autant de
gens en colère c'est qu'il ya bien une
raison ça fait un peu comme claude de
koh lanta tu voulais que ce soit claude
et c'est pas claude finalement donc les
gens sont en colère après moi j'ai kiffé
parce que j'ai appris qu'on pouvait
construire pour en lego de 506 c'est à
dire tu peux poser une voiture sur un
pont en lego ça c'est que les gouttes la
gueule on ne l'a d'or on a le droit de
même déçu mais on n'a pas le droit de
dire comme la tricherie parce qu'on a
dit c'est que l'incroyable ou non c'est
pas son rédac on va chier pardon mais il
ya des gens qui aiment pas la démocratie
il ya eu un lâcher sa tournée aucune des
contractions là bas non mais écoutez les
goûts chacun voit midi à sa porte fâché
vous savez c'est très beau votre collier
là un cadeau ah bah ça c'est un cadeau
apparemment c'est quelqu'un qui vous
oui colas pernice nous est juste une
chose qui n'a pas joué au tour de table
avec des lego mois moi j'ai pas très bon
il y en a très peu
guy saint hyacinthe et là c'est
l'intervieweur là c'est quand même le
top chef des lego barbie assurait sa
demande et je sais pas si vous avez vu
ce qu'ils ont fait moi je serais
incapable de faire ne serait ce qu'un
pour cent de ce qu'ils ont fait mais qui
sont ultra légitime et ils sont là pour
juger mais tout le monde regarde c'est
une histoire à succès comme si oui
pourquoi tu as dit oui parce qu'il n'a
pas compris la question si j'étais
choquée par les téléspectateurs
donc j'ai regardé il a dit oui il a
raison c'est nous tient au pas compris
moi c'est vous qui avez pas compris le
sens qu'il comprend l'émission
apparemment marché koh lanta on n'est
pas content on a misé françois content
on a un incroyable talent on n'est pas
content look là on a ça on est pas
content c'est comme d'habitude façon les
français sont là que pour râler surtout
sur internet et a presque le sujet de
l'émission c'est vrai que c'est spécial
dans le sens où t'as pas quand on
regarde le grand pâtissier par exemple
bon bah là ça va passer sur wii le grand
pas ne sympathise légaux il ya des
passionnés en france ils ont un confrère
entre passionnés
je sais pas si ça passionne autant que
la pâtée à mâcon avec lego masters ce
que les jeux d'enfants
on le voit en poupe on a en exclusivité
à relier je remercie m6 d'ailleurs nous
l'avoir donné le nouveau programme qui
arrivera sur m6 dès la rentrée prochaine
merci de nous l'avoir
après une première saison réussie avec
lego master's m6 revient avec un concept
encore plus ouf que personne n'attendait
oubliées les petites briques et fait
place à dr maboul masters
un jeu avec de la tension déry et
parfois même
hélas
le nez rouge du patient batik clignoter
en direct docteur maboule master's avec
eric antoine bientôt sur m6 moi je suis
content pour eric antoine parce que ça
et je suis très très heureux pour lui
eric et voilà ça m'a fait plaisir qu'il
écarterait excepté appelé parce que vous
vous appelez parce que vous lui avez dit
que ça allait cartonner rappelé eric il
m'a laissé un petit message
la première à la le lendemain matin pour
nous remercier
voilà eric antoine koch embrasse fort
oui il faut quand même reconnaître m6
est la seule chaîne historique qui
tentent des trucs en prime t elle m'a
aussi à régler la marque g et france 2
aussi
effronté français sur l'ailé gauche
français qui les aurait mis vous dites
la fusée l'ailé gauche ce n'est qu'un
système 6000 de reims étaient les
premiers mètres de la télé-réalité télé
1er mai de l'économie et capitale la
merde et les gauchos sa culotte et en
prime et que ça marche c'est bien beau
mais franchement la plaine montante à
toutes les chaînes france 3 et font
plein de portes at il évolué mais ça
marche mais bonjour g qui ont bien
marché
voilà la boîte à secrets ça a cartonné
ben voilà tf1 ils ont dansé plein de
nouveaux trucs aussi il faut avoir la
foi vous et marche arrêt et france 2 ils
ont lancé aussi beaucoup de nouvelles
choses
donc c'était une bonne intervention
n'est pas la meilleure récompense les
téléspectateurs delphine voulait dire
quelque chose sur l'ego master way sur
une émission comme ça ce sera encore
mieux si les téléspectateurs pouvaient
voter et donc dû pas mal mais pas toutes
ces polémiques en fait et c'est la même
chose pour se pendre
la france a un incroyable talent ça la
même chose en fait pour légitimer une
émission et pour légitimer une vainqueur
il faudrait comme pour miss france que
les gens s'ils sont régalés il faudra le
faire aussi bien que ces bandits rivaux
directs ne sait pas on dirait que c'est
compliqué de destruction exaltant et la
légaux saison